[Music]
we got a sponsor today very very much
thanks you two very very much thank you
to him him
so what hims is I don't want to butcher
it and there's a lot of very specific
things and it's a new company so I'm
gonna go based off these notes hims
exists to help guys know that having an
issue with their hair their wee-wee or
their skin isn't weird not handling is
weird that's true because I had like
something on my weawwy one day and I was
so scared and I Web MD dit and I've told
all my friends about it and they're like
you need to go to a doctor so I did see
that's good but a lot of people out
there I guess they're scared or they
they feel what's the word I mean if I
had something like this I wouldn't have
to go to the doctor yeah I'll be I'm too
scared to go to the doctor because
you'll get personalized recommendations
for prescription and non-prescription
products based on a conversation with a
real doctor mm-hmm and they cut out
pharma companies and other middlemen for
huge savings so whatever you need is
extremely direct and can get it from the
comfort of your own home we today have a
hair loss package and it says here hey
guy you're taking the first step right
now high-five my dude this is a kit of
uncomplicated yes they work solutions to
combat hair loss this still from years
of testing and expertise but here's the
thing you've got to use them everyday
straight-up
old-fashioned patience pays off result
can take three months its sky it's not
magic
call text or email anytime you have a
question we're excited for you see you
around town hims
that's pretty nice I recently got an
email from a fan who's like Joe how do
you keep your hair like so volume n big
and what do you do to it what's your
hair care regimen and all that and I was
like I'm sorry man I can't help you
because I just take showers well I kind
of felt sorry for him cause he was like
yeah so I'm 28 and I'm starting to bald
and I know I I don't know how to prevent
that from happening so I'm like dang you
just need a couple drops of 5% minoxidil
but not Dain that [ __ ] looks super
medical there's a gift thing here
surprise or surprise gifts matches
because when you grow out
here you can burn it all off no I'm just
kidding I don't know so matches haired
rose pill Shampoo there's pills in this
one what is it gummies oh it's a
multivitamin supplement yeah that's
pretty cool man
these are the vitamins that promote
healthy looking hair nails and skin and
the key nutrients that support a healthy
heart nerves and digestion so you don't
have to look like a Romanian gymnast to
feel like a Romanian gymnast does that
are these hang Romanians are like
vampires anyways thanks again hams for
the sponsorship and if you guys want to
get this go ahead and check this link
right here I'm gonna put it right there
or in a description box you could go
ahead and click a rule yeah
WWF our hands calm for /jk news okay
guys so if you're interested check out
their website go ahead and click the
link in the description box below and
you can get this comprehensive kit for
just $5 now on to our video in mr.
lonely news submitted by Happy Holidays
JK it's Merry Christmas and some people
love to say that now they get all
offended his Merry Christmas okay
it's Happy Holidays so you could combine
Christmas and New Year's and chanock oh
no it's like all the other nobody
celebrates Kwanzaa I actually have never
seen anybody celebrate Kwanzaa thank you
they made it up to have their own thing
okay yeah they made it up to celebrate
their own thing just like we made up
Christmas thank you there we go
Reacher's say that being single is
harder on men than it is on women that
is so our babies now what age because
being single is kind of cool Yeah right
not as not if you're older I don't want
to do all none of my skin paperwork I
don't want to clean we got used to a
certain level of what they do for us so
mind you if you were only with her for
like the first three four months you'll
be a different story but now she has
integrated herself into your system mmm
now you can't get rid of her vacuum but
that's what's crazy because girls go
through the same thing right men
integrate themselves into the female
system oh we don't we open peanut butter
jars what
we may know what do we make more work on
you yeah yeah yeah we saw so without us
you have initiative to do these things
know our bosses our house would be
spotless excuse me my house would be
spotless if not for Nikki dude oh dude
that's different Astor let her defend
herself all right don't talk about my
house like the inside of her car which
is nuts what a girl's car so [ __ ]
good I don't know it's crazy right let's
go to your car right now come you take
the camera out of your bag she's like a
neat freak though I am I bet you your
trucks dirty know everything like one
container thing because like Mariel to
she's very particular about her
apartment right she does discos here
this goes here this goes here you don't
touch that you go to her car look like
someone's looking for a nickel and some
kind of weird crabs and couldn't find it
do when I get in Nikki's car there's an
audible crunch sound for me crunching
all the [ __ ] empty water bottles on
the ground of the car cause she doesn't
want a little right because this is
literally her hot she goes that's me
right I have hard black banana peels
inside of my car because they've been
there for a long time it's fossilized
little petrified bananas that kind of
[ __ ] in your cupholders - cool yeah see
you know what's funny though is like I
don't mind my mess but if someone did
that like if a girl did that I'm like
she's disgusting you hypocrite it's true
how come you're fun with your bathroom
toilet being all [ __ ] up if it's yours
but then if you go into somebody else's
you like I know I got pee stains all
over my toilet but yeah there's a new
study by a British research firm found
that 61% of single women reported they
were content on their own men on the
other hand were own we're not
comfortable being alone because only 49%
say that they were content without a
mate and uh it's the wording why you
can't tell guys hey are you cool with
not having [ __ ] they're gonna say not
Yeah right
I need a half sec I'm pretty sure they
didn't ask if you're good with that read
the survey use the word like content are
you happy yeah
content I know what that means what the
[ __ ] oh no okay link out of my face pal
yeah come on now I make content on
YouTube don't use yield English James
Bible army yeah study also found that
guys are much more likely to want to
partner up than women because 75 percent
of women said that they hadn't actively
pursued finding a partner in the past
year but compared to 65 percent of men
who said the same but girls don't have
to they get chased all around the place
yeah they're probably I just need to
stay single there's too many guys it's
so easy but guys all shot I get the
[ __ ] uh-huh yeah Oh guys I crazy walk
by like give me your slaves like what I
imagine a single isn't like me being
alone though it's just me not being
dedicated to one person something about
you talking about that wearing that
Mickey Mouse sweatshirt that is the
saddest thing you know what you know
what that's what day you know what you
like was not bad is great yes three
singles fine twice yeah because they're
also like saying here that guys since
you know like society like social
pressures to keeping your internalize
your feelings a lot but then once you
guys are in a relationship it's easier
for you guys to express your feelings
no I express my feelings all time so
much maybe not you but I guess other
guys and so that's why they feel like
they they're more comfortable to be in a
relationship rather than women we have
friends and we always went out I don't
know friends at all of course we don't
talk about our feelings it's just weird
thing that we don't thought I did
janitor weekends women do do that we
don't feel like we need to have a mate
girls are more emotionally healthy and
we need someone to help express that
stuff yeah I think he's like you're
always so quiet about like what are you
thinking and I'm like yeah I'm okay cuz
I don't think girls understand that our
mind just shuts down into blankness so
true should ever think it about it's
nothing like are you holding something
back now
like completely mapping me she goes what
are you thinking of and I'm just like I
just [ __ ] on my own life
no I'll stick of nothing no right
doesn't say why do I have to lie yeah I
wasn't thinking about anything to get
worried if cuz when you say nothing is
something you're doing this is my face
Stella like this sometimes we just
screensaver comes on you know can you
picture a guy on that why do you think
guys like to meditate and do Buddhism in
shape it's like all the bugs are all
guys cuz they just like nothing and
sometimes I'm just thinking that
something so [ __ ] stupid then it's
like it's like I'm like oh I wonder if
they've invented a cup where if you have
a lid on it if you if you spilled your
cup you drink it wouldn't get on the
ground I'm oh that's a sippy cup and
then what are you thinking about and I'm
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes I'm thinking of an invention it's
already been invented it's called a
sippy cup and everyone knows about it
I'm gonna share that [ __ ] with you I'm
thinking about dudes bleaching their
[ __ ] and maybe me eating it may be
eating the dudes butt out okay you know
what I found out - it's like is that
what you wanna hear
right like the way the girls communicate
they communicate without judgement so
what they do is they blab constantly to
us
that's [ __ ] annoying as [ __ ] shut the
[ __ ] up you that's what it is if a guy
did that right it's like hey Steve you
know the color green have you ever
thought about the color green sometimes
it wise could the color green so this
class green right is that [ __ ] weird
we don't talk
doodle one thing is like it's very
arbitrary look when when they okay
doesn't have any weight yes so it sounds
like I gotta be like seriously but the
way you express it there's so much
weight on it yeah it's like oh my god is
this an emergency it's not that it's
because we can feel a lot of intense
emotions stupidity a lot of intense
emotions fairly quickly where you guys
only can feel one emotion no but you
guys read into everything though yes
okay cuz cuz okay
I'm gonna get really killed for this
again so so every morning almost every
morning nikki has to tell me about what
she dreamt about last night and it's a
always a very long sentence long
paragraph of a story I'm recording this
for Nikki I got you Nik look about I
don't give one single [ __ ] not even an
iota
I don't give a molecule of a [ __ ] about
it but I nod my head and I understand
Charlie I contact but I don't give a
[ __ ] and the whole time in my head I'm
just screaming I don't give a [ __ ] it
doesn't make sense I don't understand
the story there's no point to the story
please just stop talking about this so
thank you she had a conversation right
that same conversation with a wonderful
girl for single and then one really Wow
or you that's how they react do you guys
like to boost each other up just think
about how you guys go out to clubs right
that's what you guys do
oh my god where'd you get those earrings
those earrings are great I was gonna get
for myself but that does look better on
you so I didn't get cut knew you're
gonna get it that's what you guys do
right yeah we do yo wait a minute back
the [ __ ] truck up but that's what you
idiots love about women that now you
guys can feel like what your [ __ ] the
[ __ ] that user doing is important and we
appreciate it and you can share that
[ __ ] look she has no idea why we love
Hyde I'm dead I don't feel that you know
what this [ __ ] said
wait you know what this [ __ ] said
while he was trying to get [ __ ]
you don't say [ __ ] anymore but he
already got a kid from I know cute ass
kid yeah he's good alright what do you
say what do you say though he's lying
[ __ ] you know what I always invite
you to do things because you're kind of
like my cheering section sick having
like my mom I heard him say that many
times I always want you to show up
basically I'm [ __ ] going yeah Thank
You Tiffany friend my back who sit in a
[ __ ] hotel room with the [ __ ]
newborn so thick strauder ass book
though Yeah right but I was still there
no I didn't I wasn't like shooting and
then I hear the echoes up I came back to
the casino and you're like yeah probably
sticking here all day what was the Rosie
had been for by the way just for himself
always wanted to go there was a good
workout yep what a minute doesn't count
it was just for a gift you're supposed
to that she forgives exactamundo
do that for you did you get this that
you wanted do you yes I did she took me
to a bride midnight concert night
through my bouncers at him you cease
support yeah but there was no support
you were just doing there
your heart wasn't you want
when they're with the newborn she's
gonna highlight the [ __ ] new boy
that's hard if Bart went to your recital
but he was on the phone all day taking
care of animals you don't have a [ __ ]
child only tip could speak do you have
an example then you're so new at this
you can't say that yet I know you brand
new mom shut the [ __ ] up in a mom for
three weeks that's the hardest [ __ ]
time to be a mom stammers he's more of a
panting you you had your mom there to
have two cats that's hard in your
[ __ ] face
[Music]